[Music]
foreign
police have finally charged a man in
connection to the murder of Tupac Shakur
in 1996. I think he was only 25 years
old and what he was able to achieve in
that time none of us can compare it felt
like there was a cover-up and that we
would never find out the truth because
so many people were involved in this
they blame pay Diddy they blame Suge
Knight Suge Knight was in the car and
even he was suspected in setting up the
shooting because Tupac was going to
leave his record label and there was all
that beef with a Notorious B.I.G even
the police were suspects in this because
a lot of police officers were working
when they were off duty for these crime
guns like death row uh the record label
that Suge Knight was head of who Tupac
worked on and P Diddy as well he had
cops on the payroll so nobody was
trustable in this scenario people gave
up hope a long time ago that we would
ever get the answers Tupac's mother was
campaigning for decades to find out who
did this to her son and she has since
died there is no justice for anyone
really it's too little too late but at
least we have an answer now now let me
take you back in time to the night of
the murder September 7th 1996. this was
the night of the Mike Tyson fight
against Selden in latter Vegas Tyson and
Tupac were very good friends Tupac had
reference Tyson in a lot of his songs
and as always Tupac when he rolled up to
these places he was deep he had all of
his guys with him and it was a problem
for anyone who they recognized
unfortunately for a guy called Orlando
Anderson who was a [__] a rival gang to
the Bloods that Tupac had with him they
spotted him in the lobby of the hotel
where the fight was taking place so
you'll see the CCTV footage here in the
hotel lobby Tupac had already attacked
Orlando Anderson they'd had a previous
beef and you can see the guy in the
white here that Suge Knight who was
putting a beat down on this guy as well
they're kicking him and as far as
they're concerned it's Point proven to
practice saying walking out of the hotel
here strutting as if he owns the place
now as far as we're away Tupac and Shug
then make the decision to go to a
nightclub called the 662 which is the
digits on your phone for M or B it's mob
owned Mafia type [__] where they've
owned this nightclub and this is where
they hang up and this is the final
photograph ever taken of Tupac and Shug
uh sug at the driver's side Tupac and
the passenger side now obviously what
was known at that moment was two pack
pulled up at some traffic lights on the
Las Vegas Strip and another car which
was a white Cadillac pulled up alongside
and emptied the clip into the car Tupac
was hit killed he did survive for about
six days I think it was six or seven
days after the initial shot went in but
he wasn't conscious he'd been hit
through the lungs which had filled up
with blood and you know he was never
going to be the same again after that
which people didn't really accept
because he'd also been shot like a year
before this and survived that so Tupac
was like Immortal and indestructible so
for him to actually be shot again people
kind of were just like he'll pull
through because he didn't die
immediately people just believed he'd
pull through Orlando Anderson was
obviously the main suspect being that he
was the guy who got jumped by these guys
however he was killed not long after
this and as were a lot of people as you
can imagine because in these wars that's
the way it was but one guy who was in
the car didn't get killed and
unfortunately for him he's decided to do
YouTube interviews about 20 odd years
later and is basically incriminated
himself introducing kiefy D oh dear guys
so we went to the six six people uh
Tupac and sure they never show up so we
left so Orlando and his guys were
actually waiting at this 662 Club
waiting for Suge Knight in Tupac they
didn't show up so these guys went out
looking for them all the chase was like
him
you
pulled up I was in the front seat
[Music]
you said the shots came from the back
big Dre Orlando who shot two buck
they came before the cold on the streets
it just came from the back seat bro so
he's claiming oh it came from the back
seat I was in the passenger seat I mean
you would wouldn't you like because what
he's trying to do here is get all the
clout for being involved and allude to
the fact that it was me but yeah I came
from the back seat and those guys just
so happen to be dead unlikely story and
the fact is he's been doing interviews
about this for years now it kind of goes
back to what Chris Rock once said about
if you ever want to get away with uh a
murder just put a demo tape in the
pocket of whoever you kill because
police don't care about rapper deaths
these are interviews for years ago Keith
I feel remorse for Tupac but attacking
Orlando gave us the green light this is
four years ago how it took this long is
insane so this is the mug shot of KPD
AKA Dwayne Davis and he's taken into
custody by Las Vegas detectives he's 60
years old and the the brother of Tupac
more Prem who is his stepbrother has
actually slammed detectives and said
we've been through Decades of pain
they've known about this guy he's been
running his mouth for years so why now
that is the interesting thing they've
clearly known about this guy for a long
time what what has changed is someone
not paying up to the cops who were
keeping him you know safe maybe there's
no way that they've just randomly
thought you know we'll get him now this
was four years ago he was given these
interviews so Chief Deputy district
attorney Mark d g m Como has described
Davis as an on-ground on-site commander
who ordered the death of Shakur so while
he may not have been the one to pull the
trigger because he was in the front as
he said he came from the back he's
probably handed them the gun and I think
there's even footage of him saying that
so now whether or not he pulled the
trigger he was in command and they are
going to charge him as if he ordered the
death for 27 years
guy is bragging as if
we finally cracked it mate the guy was
doing YouTube interviews four years ago
were basically telling you leading every
breadcrumb there yeah it was me to
announce the arrest of 60 year old
Dwayne Keith Davis aka keithy for the
murder of Tupac Shakur well I know
there's been many people who did not
believe that the murder of Tupac Shakur
was important to this Police Department
I'm here to tell you that was simply not
the case you can't give it I Told You So
and it took you 20 [__] seven years
man it's still sorry it took this long
but at least we got the guy you don't
get the gloat now this man's doing the
Victory lap Who's laughing now huh still
the criminal he spent the majority of
his life as a free man he was just about
to collect this old age pensioner bus
pass and now you're locked in the middle
his life's basically over anyway our
goal at lvmpd has always been to hold
those accountable and responsible for
Tupac's violent murder accountable
just like we do for every homicide
victim in our city he's just really
using this as a as an opportunity to do
a good PR so let's go back to the cop
now who found Tupac at the scene of the
crime and actually held Tupac as he took
some of his last conscious breaths check
this out this man doesn't live far from
kiefy day they lived like a couple of
streets away from each other and this is
the guy who was investigating the case
they always say it's the one closest to
you mostly everybody who is involved in
this whole incident is dead at this
point
so
um I think you know you run your mouth
you you talk you talk yourself into a
search warrant uh maybe maybe you've
even talked yourself into a murder
charge you know we don't know that yet
we do know because he has been charged
with murder and they have found bullets
in the house bullets that potentially
could link him to the murder it's
unlikely after 27 years that would be
the same bullet but apparently they
potentially are from a similar gun and
they're going to obviously run those
checks the reason this gets even more
interesting now is because of who keefy
D is linked to there was always
speculation that P Diddy was the one who
was ordering the hit on Tupac because
they'd had long-standing beef Tupac was
talking mad [__] about him and also he
did he publicly had put a warrant out
for a death row chain that they all used
to wear he put money out saying if you
bring me one of those I'm gonna give you
whatever it was and you don't get chains
like that but peace yeah like so he'd
already made threats in that way and the
problem for pay did he is kiefy day has
publicly spoken about looking after P
Diddy so I want a bad track you said
that um he was on top of the world until
you met puffy what do you mean by that
man she I'll get 300 kilos a month man
baldly man brother Lush come show some
love
that's all I can [__] say show some
love brother love
you know [__]
brother I'll be seeing you doing your
little pretty Jazz and all that man show
some love on me
come on man don't be like that brother
love I was on top of the world until I
met your [__] ass dude [__] is
wrong dude come on homie I need
something to throw a dog a bone or
something to convert that in English
what he's saying is is I got involved
with P Diddy P Diddy went to the moon
killed it made all of his millions and
now I'm sitting here where's my love
where's my Hondo I'm the one struggling
now and I looked after you apparently
qpd has detailed the motive for the
shooting was a retaliation and to
collect the one million dollar Bounty he
claimed Sean Puffy Combs AKA P Diddy
offer to him and his gang to kill Tupac
and Suge Knight P Diddy has yet to be
arrested but refuses to address the
allegations in public interviews now
that this guy has been arrested P Diddy
must be [__] himself given the
nature of the the hit record hit him up
by Tupac where he went up both P Diddy
and the Notorious B.I.G given the fact
that Tupac already blamed this first
shooting that he survived on P Diddy and
pig who else had the motive to do this
people suggested Suge Knight was behind
it because Tupac was wanting to leave
the record label he wanted him to better
dead than alive somewhere else but Shug
was in the car he got a bullet grazed
off of his head like are you really
going to put yourself in that situation
this makes a lot more sense given that
there is an established link between P
Diddy and keithy if your P Diddy now and
you've had Decades of success after this
all went down to now end up in prison
would be horrendous for him it's funny
because Eminem even alluded to this like
a year or two ago in a disregular to
Machine Gun Kelly Machine Gun Kelly
assigned to P Diddy and Eminem must have
been pissed off at the fact that P Diddy
had allowed a Machine Gun Kelly to come
at him and starts pointing fingers
Eminem says in the song kill shot but
this idiot's boss pops pills and tells
him he's got skills but Kells the day
you put out hit as the dear Diddy admits
that he put out the hit that got popped
killed he literally said it and if
there's anyone who should know about
this [__] it's a guy who's best mates
with Dr Dre and has been in rap at the
highest level for the last 30 [__]
years himself but he does see at the end
I'm just playing Diddy you know I love
you so that gives you that right was he
being serious but yes everything points
to yes P Diddy killed Tupac you heard it
here first I'm in London they can't get
me and I remember like I utilized in
Tupac and loving his music when I was
really young and wondering like is he
alive and all of these [__] you know
theories about being in Jamaica or
whatever the [__] which does seem better
than death but all these years later we
finally find out that it was Orlando
Anderson who pulled the trigger kiefy D
who gave him the gun and and set it up
and P Diddy who paid them done done
another case solved by detective Geordie
you're welcome let me know what you
think of all of this in the comments
below because pretty much everyone who
was involved in this is either dead or
in jail look at Suge Knight he is in
jail he's a shadow of the man he was so
really there is no more retribution to
be had it is just jail for Kitty day but
if they bring down P Diddy a billionaire
wow that is Mendel and he really he's
recently been giving all of his
publishing rights back to the artists
that he basically held hostage for two
decades so he's feeling a bit charitable
weirdly lately I don't know why let me
know what you think in the comments
below hit that like button stay
subscribed to the true Geordie YouTube
channel thanks for watching and I'll see
you on the next one